attack said buttery soft and i didn't
believe them they're right they're
buttery soft i keep putting my hands
down to make sure i'm still wearing
pants these are just like
getting a kiss all over your butt
we're going to be styling these athleta
elation types automatically like i'm
drawn to this
wide waistband and definitely the high
seam this is kind of my ideal material
really beautiful material actually like
thicker than i expected
super stretchy which i love not too
thick
not too thin it holds your body in like
where you need it to
i think i know exactly how to start this
outfit
so let's get started so overall i'd say
my style is pretty
eclectic i like thrift store finds i
like
a lot of cheetah print obviously denim
pops of color i think would look good
i think my personal style's kind of all
over the place sometimes it's a cross
between like a 90s mom
but also sometimes i really jump into
trends
i kind of dress like a 18th century
vampire boy most of the time um
so i think i'd really like to
incorporate athletic wear
with my personal style so you know like
ruffles a little bit of dark academia um
kind of like a fun vampire goth but
um on the go in a pair of tights
these feel really soft really buttery
too
so i've got this athleta conscious crop
little crop top here
i want to add some layers i love
halloween so this is a fun little candy
corn
sweater i've got some flannel here
i have lived in spandex literally my
entire life
man i say that i don't mean that
jokingly because i started gymnastics
when i was two years old
my senior quote in high school was my
personality changes almost as often as
my clothing does
so i do kind of have an eclectic closet
i mostly wear leggings and tights it's
it's kind of like my uniform
so i'm feeling really great about this
because this is such a great base for me
to incorporate into my style because i
can either
wear it you know like athleisure wear or
i could dress it up and put a little
cute jacket on it these are
really really soft and really
comfortable these hit
right where i want them to hit these are
just like getting a kiss all over your
butt
so today i'm thinking of rocking these
black tights with maybe
a white neutral top and mix up the shoe
it can be dressed up more business
casual or it can be dressed down
with heels shoes different jackets it is
cold right now
in detroit michigan so of course i have
like two jacket selections to add to it
[Music]
so this is just a tank top i think it's
really cute really lightweight
but i'm probably gonna pair it under
this faux fur camel colored
jacket so i lead such an active life and
i like my style to follow
especially with bold statement pieces so
i'm an athlete and a wardrobe stylist so
i have to find pieces that are so
functional where i can literally go to
the gym
and then be on set
[Music]
being a mom i'm always trying to be
comfortable so this is definitely an
everyday type of
tight for me it's cold outside so i want
to be
comfortable and cash if it's really cold
outside then i'll do the carlton and
have a sweater draped around me
i absolutely love neutrals you guys look
fifty shades of brown
you can't go wrong with a turtleneck i
really
like denim so i think i'm gonna stick
with that i put on this nice little
spooky candy corn sweater
but it's still kind of open so it's kind
of casual i
loving the yellow leather with the
leopard and the
tights you guys they are high-waisted i
knew they were i was double checking
just to let you know
i love how high these tights go they're
the perfect high waist
they're so supportive and the
compression is amazing
i am loving the athletic conscious crop
but i
don't love all the different variable
layers
so i went ahead and tried this on and i
just i want something a little brighter
with a little bit of pop of color and
something that has a little more pizzazz
this feels this feels a little bland so
we're going to try something else
i think a lighter denim would look
really cute with this outfit
i can really move in these i love that
they're like versatile too
i can definitely do yoga um it's comfy
i'm not super super feeling i feel like
it's giving halloween
vibes and it's not that time of the year
i'm trying on the athleta up tempo tank
i absolutely love this it's so soft and
i love this color
i tied it here for a little style
i added a little camo jacket super cute
i love the jacket
love the white stitching on it love you
know the hardware the buttons
so i'm kind of thinking that maybe i
want to
spice this up with a little bit of a
biscuity wardrobe i'm not a fan of the
glitter tank
they just have such a nice shape to them
the leggings that i don't like that
we're covering
so much of it fluffy kind of long line
top going into the very sleek bottom but
i'm not really sold on this look
i feel like i need a little more pink a
little more spice whatever that may be
it's not all the way me i think that i'm
gonna go back to what my gut
is telling me and go back to the
original outfit
it goes like renaissance going into
elizabethan silhouette
i think this outfit is absolutely it
this is kind of like
california means kansas but like spooky
still you know
party on the top blacks on the bottom
which is going to be great for my next
zoom meeting this feels so much more fun
than just wearing dirty old sweats like
this is really chic and put together and
kind of stylized
loving the coat very comfy then i also
have the white
shirt i really like this and i bet when
i pair it up with some jewelry maybe
some sunnies
i love a pop of pink and i can
definitely see myself wearing this
to the gym you guys i'm pregnant so like
the baby
is secure the package is secure up here
loving the fit
i styled my athleta elation tight
with my most comfortable chunky socks
and my dad
sneakers because i'm always on the go
then i layered it with this mock
turtleneck
my very cute and sporty sweater to go
over my turtleneck
and last but not least i have my carlton
sweater
for my final look i decided to pair
the elation tights and the conscious
cropped sports bra
with a double denim look a chambray
shirt
and a denim jacket over top with
my yellow baseball cap and some gold
jewelry
for my final look i decided to pair the
athleta elation tight
with a fun study sports bra and i ended
up throwing on
another pink like a crop top over i
finished it off with a gold chain
red lipstick a leopard scrunchie and
this
beautiful hot pink trench i'm completely
obsessed
you can never have too much pink so for
my final look i really wanted to bring
out my bold statement style
i paired the tights with this maroon
silk top i'm wearing some gold jewelry
my shoes are probably my favorite pair
of shoes
ever and then i have this white bag just
to
bring everything full circle so i put my
final look together
um using this thrifted cream blazer
embroidered this piece from an indie og
and lolita fashion brand put on some
really nice matching shoes
pointy cute old-fashioned and
also incorporated some of my jewelry to
kind of bring back
the the black and also just incorporate
more of the gothic theme into the outfit
i put a flannel over the tights and then
i went ahead and put a motorcycle jacket
to give it like that edge
and i think it came out really nice some
little black chelsea boots here and put
those over the tights
if i want it to be functional if i want
to go straight from spin class
into an actual function i can do so i
chose to pair my athleta elation tights
with a cropped marigold turtleneck a
white blazer with gold buttons and white
slouchy
boots and i finished it off with a white
and gold envelope purse with a floral
paisley design on it i chose to style it
with
a really fun black hat i also chose to
wear this bright yellow top with it
and then i'm pairing a trench cut over
my yellow top
i'm also wearing some black boots i do
this on purpose
not to be stylish necessarily but to
just give me some hype
uh because i'm four foot eleven and just
getting a couple inches
really makes people respect you more i
decided to
do a halfway tucked in shirt thing into
the tights
with some nice cute white dots and then
have my big
jacket over the shoulder and last but
not least i decided to add a cute little
purple bag
just to add a pop of color to the entire
outfit everything
the jacket the tank top it's all
secondhand but i really think the star
of the show is definitely
the tights i can do so much with it the
whole look just speaks to me and i
wanted something comfortable
yet stylish at the same time